It sailed through space at an unimaginable
speed.
A grand mechanical construction unlike anything
we’d ever see on our planet.
A terrifying weapon to end all weapons.
Oppenheimer said of the atomic bomb, “Now,
I am become death, the destroyer of worlds,”
but comparatively, this device made the atom
bomb look like little more than a cherry bomb.
This deadly machine’s orders were simple:
Take a direct course to earth, activate, and
wipe out all life.
Leave the planet barren, with not even the
smallest squirming microbes remaining.
And this device, this Destroyer, was more
than capable of accomplishing this task.
It’d been smooth sailing for millions of
miles.
All diagnostics were looking positive.
Within a mere decade or so, the human race
would be purged from the cosmos.
Then, faster than the pre-programmed destroyer
could react, a huge, yellowish-green shape
appeared in front of it.
The Destroyer’s mysterious creators, in
their not-quite-infinte intelligence, had
planned for all the major celestial bodies
in Earth’s solar system, including Jupiter,
but for reasons unknown, they hadn’t calculated
the presence of Io, Jupiter’s third-largest
Galilean moon.
The Destroyer struck it at incredible speed,
causing a mighty explosion and completely
altering its perfect trajectory.
Alarms were sounding as the Destroyer hurtled
down onto the lower atmosphere of Jupiter.
This alteration was unprecedented.
Mayday, mayday.
In some distant galaxy, screens were flashing
red, and the Creators suddenly registered
that this mission may not be so simple after
all.
They would need to make adjustments.
The impact into Jupiter triggered the Destroyer’s
attack protocol: Drawing from its limitless
energy source, it activated its hyper-advanced
anti-matter weaponry, causing spacial disruptions
and atmospheric shifts that created a huge,
red vortex on the surface of the gas giant,
one that would later become known to earth
based astronomers as the Great Red Spot.
It’s 16,350 kilometers wide, which is 1.3
times the size of planet earth, and exists
as a kind of hell that almost no being could
endure.
A constant, swirling nightmare with 432 km/h
wind speeds.
In other words, the exact kind of nightmare
it would have turned earth into if ever it
had reached its actual intended destination.
But no matter.
This was just a minor setback, all things
considered - Such contingencies had been planned
for from the start.
The Creators, back in the Triangulum Galaxy,
roughly three million light years away from
the Milky Way, simply began transmitting new
orders to the crashed, malfunctioning Destroyer:
“Unit is damaged: Repair.”
And that’s exactly what it began to do.
It’s unknown how they were able to communicate,
let alone travel over such a vast distance,
but systems that would be impossible to even
explain to humans suddenly began to kick in.
It released a legion of hardy, self-made octopoid
repair drones that began to search for the
machine’s missing parts, presumably hidden
within the gasses of Jupiter or pulled in
by the gravity of its nearby moons.
Other drones would remain at the Destroyer’s
side, conducting repairs and guiding its vital
systems.
Presumably, to this machine and its creators,
humans are like mayflies: Insignificant creatures
with such tiny lifespans.
Here today, gone tomorrow.
The machine would conduct its repairs and
be upon us within a mere few centuries, barely
even diverting from the schedule.
The one thing the creators didn’t anticipate
was the formation of a little organization
called the SCP Foundation, perhaps the only
hope humanity has in repelling this doomsday
weapon.
The question we need to answer today is: Will
they be enough?
Terrifyingly, this device has been intent
on our destruction since long before the SCP
Foundation was even a glint in humanity’s
eye.
It entered our solar system and crashed on
Jupiter all the way back in 1665.
We know this thanks to the writings of Italian
Astronomer Giovanni Cassini, who recorded
detailed notes in his journal on what we would
later dub SCP-2399.
On October 8th, 1665, he wrote:
“I have observed something extraordinary
in the heavens.
Last night, as I gazed through my looking
glass, I saw what appeared to be a star of
great luminescence streak through the far
reaches of our solar system.
I have never recorded an object moving so
fast; it had surpassed the outer planets in
fewer than two hours!
As I watched, by my own two eyes, I saw it
slow as it closed on Jupiter, make a sharp
turn, and disappear into the planet itself.
I saw many bursts of light afterwards, but
although I continued to peer at it until the
Sun broke, I saw no additional disturbances
in the night sky.
I must continue to document these changes,
and will alert my colleagues when the day
is upon me.”
On October 15th:
“I took Peter to my observation point last
night, but a week from the night I saw the
fire rain upon Jupiter in the heavens.
He brought along his own looking glass, and
together we aimed our view upon the giant.
To our surprise, a magnificent change has
occurred!
Where once the distant world only showed bands
of color, there is now a great red spot where
the star came to rest on the surface of Jupiter.
Peter was incredulous, of course, that such
an amazing discovery could have taken place
before our very eyes.
I will continue to take note of this.”
On October 18th:
“Tonight as I peered through my looking
glass, I swear on my life that I observed
what looked to me like explosions and starbursts
emanating from our red spot.
I fear my mind is playing tricks on me, for
there has been no record of such violent outbursts
by a heavenly body since the dawn of astronomy.
I will consult with Peter on the morrow, and
hopefully glean from him some advice on the
matter.”
On October 19th:
“Peter sees the same as I!
As I approached him with my concerns, he leveled
the same with me, and through our following
discussion we concluded that it must be a
powerful reaction to the falling star I saw
upon the first night, and not a product of
our own shortcomings.
I am left wondering what cataclysmic event
must be taking place upon our heavenly neighbour.
Our work to document this must go on.”
And the work of documenting SCP-2399 has indeed
gone on, for centuries.
Just as the machine itself has never once
ceased in its extensive repairs.
It was first spotted by modern humanity, and
by extension, the SCP Foundation, in 1963.
As soon as the technology existed to send
satellites up to Jupiter, the Foundation began
studying this frightening new foe up close,
trying to get the true measure of its abilities.
They discovered that the weapon has a mysterious
internal power supply that seems impossible
to run down, as well as an advanced targeting
system, self-repair abilities, anti-matter
weapons, and matter-disrupting capabilities.
It also appears to have advanced shielding
systems that make destroying it currently
impossible.
And seeing as it’s a massive piece of military
machinery 514.18 million miles away from earth,
it’s impossible to truly contain.
That’s why the Foundation has rearranged
its priorities into two new prongs regarding
SCP-2399.
The first is suppressing information to avoid
panic.
In order to achieve this, the Foundation has
embedded agents in all major observatories
to suppress any sightings of the machine,
and has also been conducting an active disinformation
campaign to keep it out of the public consciousness.
The second prong of their containment procedure
is cutting off the transmissions between the
Destroyer’s creators in the Triangulum Galaxy,
and the Destroyer itself.
Actually achieving this goal took a miraculous
feat in aerospace engineering: The BARRIER
Satellite Array.
This was an unprecedented long-range satellite
array positioned in Jupiter’s higher orbit,
designed for the specific purpose of blocking
the electromagnetic transmissions inbound
for the Destroyer.
These messages are intercepted, decoded, and
logged on the Foundation database.
The satellites have also been granted some
minor offensive capabilities for use in extreme
emergencies.
SCP-2399 has been given the Keter Class due
to its unique containment difficulties.
It’s also been given Disruption Class Amida,
for the hefty possibility that reaching earth
could result in an SK-Class “Barren Earth”
End of the World Scenario.
On top of that, it has been given the risk
class “Danger”, due to the very high potential
of all this actually coming to pass.
The biggest concern for the Foundation at
present is the accelerating rate of repair
that the Destroyer seems to be exhibiting.
Back when they first observed the Destroyer
up close, it was repairing itself at a rate
of .12%.
However, that rate of repair has now risen
to .78% annually.
According to all known metrics, its current
level of functionality appears to be 59%.
If ever it reaches 75%, then, to put it mildly,
we’re all going to be in a lot of trouble.
Current projections say this is incredibly
likely to occur in the next 25 years, and
if we don’t figure out a way to stop it
before then, the earth is doomed.
The SCP Foundation received a chilling wake-up
call about the severity of the situation when
one of the BARRIER units noticed one of the
Destroyer’s repair drones zeroing in on
a piece of debris that seemed to be a part
of the Destroyer’s communications array.
Considering that the Foundation’s main weapon
against the Destroyer right now is blocking
its communication capabilities, allowing it
to repair its communications array would be
an unacceptable failure.
Because of this, BARRIER Unit 53 was ordered
to fire its onboard concussion batteries at
the drone in hopes of destroying it or at
least impeding its progress.
This was met by swift and severe prevention
and retaliation from the Destroyer.
It fired its own defensive charges, destroying
BARRIER Unit 53’s payload five kilometers
away from the repair drone.
It subsequently destroyed BARRIER Unit 53,
as well as several other BARRIER satellites
that just so happened to be in its vicinity.
This led to an order that no BARRIER Units
are permitted to engage the repair drones,
for fear that this would lead to even greater
losses.
The next attempt to fight back against SCP-2399
went by the name Project Gigas.
This was a joint project between the SCP Foundation
and 45 different nations, with the goal of
using sheer, raw firepower to destroy or at
least utterly incapacitate SCP-2399.
They would place almost 100 massive nuclear
warheads on Europa, Jupiter’s smallest Galilean
Moon, each one fitted with EMP detonators
to impede the Destroyer’s defense systems.
They would hit it with so much nuclear hellfire
that surely it would be destroyed.
Naturally, when this failed to meaningfully
damage the Destroyer, the Foundation returned
to the drawing board, daunted by the enormity
of the task before them.
The way they saw it, there was only one viable
option left: Protocol LEGIONNAIRE.
Randall McAllan, the director of the BARRIER
Project, released the following haunting memo
on the subject:
“So, SCP-2399.
Have you ever sat and wondered, maybe after
you hear about a car accident on a street
you were just on, or a bombing in a city you
were visiting, just how lucky you are to be
alive?
Just how many things have to go right for
you to continue to exist?
A few seconds too late, a few seconds too
early, and somebody reaches for something
they dropped and a busload of people run into
another busload of people.
Sometimes this kind of thing does happen,
as we've seen, far too often.
But that's what we're here for.
To protect those who can't protect themselves
from things that they wouldn't even know to
protect themselves from.
We can't do it all, though.
As many things as we've been able to contain,
as many things as we've been able to keep
under lock that would threaten to destroy
us all, still far too many remain that we
can't do anything about.
Whether they're too big, or too fast, or too
powerful, any of these things could blink
and wipe humanity from existence.
The fact that they haven't done so yet is
just luck.
SCP-2399, however, is different.
We have little information regarding SCP-2399's
motives, origins, and full capabilities.
We do not understand how it is capable of
communicating over such large distances, or
why those who constructed it (if it was, in
fact, constructed) sent it to us in the first
place.
We do not know what would happen if SCP-2399
is able to fully repair itself, or if part
of our array would break down and a message
would get through.
We do not know this, so we must assume the
worst.
Judging by what we've seen, were SCP-2399
to have reached Earth, it would have led to
our timely destruction.
But sometimes humanity gets a little help.
Sometimes something steps in the way of the
apocalypse.
For us, and for SCP-2399, it was Jupiter.
As SCP-2399 began to slow on its approach
to Earth, Cassini saw what we've been able
to ascertain; that SCP-2399 struck Io, was
damaged, and was unable to escape the gravitational
pull of Jupiter.
Its weapons activated as they were intended,
but it was Jupiter that experienced doomsday,
not us.
Eventually, though, it's likely that SCP-2399
will resume full functionality, and will likely
be able to pull away from Jupiter and proceed
to its target.
As of now, we can keep hurling bombs and EMPs
at it all we want, but we've got no indication
that any of it will so much as scratch the
thing, on the contrary, experience dictates
it would do nothing at all.
If this were to happen now, we would undoubtedly
be destroyed.
Jupiter has given us time.
For now, SCP-2399 will remain there, reassembling
itself, while we devise some way to stop it.
Like it or not, we are in an arms race with
this thing.
Our best guesses give us something like 25
years until it is able to hear past our dampening
array.
Until then, we must seize the opportunity
that has been laid before us.
We must use the time we have been given, and
not let it be wasted.
So we devised Protocol LEGIONNAIRE.
One gigantic EMP, powered by god-knows-what,
followed by a volley of nukes big enough to
wipe out our civilization a thousand times
over.
A blunt plan, and simple, and likely futile.
Our researchers, and researchers around the
globe, have yet to devise even a way to deliver
that kind of pulse, let alone a way to power
it.
There is no indication whatsoever that we
will be able to complete LEGIONNAIRE on time,
or if it will do what is intended once it
is completed.
But we must try.
We must do something.
Even if we have to drain our banks and empty
our mines, we must try.
Not often do we get a chance to see the swerving
bus that will end our lives, and step out
of the way.
Jupiter, unknowingly, has offered us that
chance.
I suggest we take it.”
You’re probably wondering: Why is McAllan
approaching this situation with such desperate
urgency?
Well, it’s because in 1996, and again in
2015, the message that the Destroyer has been
receiving changed.
It was no longer a simple order to repair.
The message now read “Unit is out of range
of target: Proceed to planet #3 in system.
Priority is target: Cease repairs.”
And if that message ever gets through, time
is already up for all of us.
Now go check out “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle
- The Full Story Compilation” and “SCP
XK Class End of the World Scenarios Explained”
for more anomalies that could wipe us off
the face of the earth!